the bachelor mansion didn't burn down
Amanda Stanton talks her relationship
and Bachelor beard news it's time for
roses and rose say hi everybody I'm
Lauren Zima and it's my birthday month
oh god Lauren you're making it about
yourself again whoa hold on I'm sorry
but I'm just so excited because GC J you
see just can you just walk in here just
really quick you guys JC just gave me
this a surprise birthday gift it's my
favorite Rose a I won't show the brant
all thanks babe and look he's got that
little pink stripe and it's tie for Rose
a thank you thinking of me and my
birthday the most important man in my
life but seriously he's single ladies
and I'm not gonna show the brand of the
Rosie because they're not sponsoring us
but you can probably guess by the bottle
it's very signature and some a listers
make it a listers that are no longer in
a relationship we have been reporting on
these wildfires and my heart's just go
out to everybody who has been impacted
by them everybody who works here DT has
family friends who live in these areas
that we literally had some people's
family members sleeping in our ET studio
so please if you can donate to the Red
Cross donate to the LA Fire Department
they need things like hydration
backpacks to help them fight the fires
and do the important work that they're
doing and just all our love to them this
week's video is gonna be bachelor news
you can booze
I can report that the bachelor mansion
is overall a source tells me got I
already need more wine it's been morning
I'm saving the wine JC gave me it wasn't
cold that's the thing this is already
chilled otherwise a big parking lot
trust me okay so where source tells me
that the main structure of the mansion
is fine it's good you know the main
structure means like where they sleep in
those bunk beds where they cook those
meals themselves where they have those
cocktails
I had a few cocktails they do that
outside as well what has been impacted
is kind of a lower than main structure
because member it seems kind of in a
cliff a lower structure where the crew
often is production is burned pretty
badly and my source says that the back
patio area which I think means I can't
confirm its the same patio but I think
means around the pool and that area has
also been badly burned and oh my god do
we love a poolside moment now luckily in
other news you can booze
filming is winding down on : under what
season of The Bachelor everybody yes
pretty much done so they filmed all the
mansion stuff already so there is time
to repair and restore the mansion to is
valori by the way if you don't know the
bachelor mansion is just owned by a
local person and he and his family just
peace out for a couple weeks for filming
each season and then they move back in
and for the show the mansion is very
much changed like different set pieces
and set dressing is brought in to look
different
obviously that man in his family don't
have like a bunch of rooms filled with
bunk beds for 25 20 something's
you know so that gets changed up and
hopefully I'm excited to see that like
you know maybe we get some new revamps
to the outside area maybe it gets like a
cool new sexy vibe like let's bring some
positivity out of a burning flame that
brought everything to ash you know let's
get sexy what rises from fire sexiness
so maybe we'll see you new back patio
situation hmm but I'm recalibrating in
honor of the mansion being a okay
overall silver Lighting's we are going
to look back at our favorite a mansion
and trans moments because if there's
something we all know the mansion for
its that flicks down driveway and people
embarking on their reality journey in
the weirdest possible ways let's not
forget when Claire Crawley entered with
a fake baby bump Oh cheers to Claire
what do you know about this
that one was brave hmm we've seen a lot
of those bachelor entrances where people
really trying to push the relationship
forward you know really accelerate it
because that's what they're gonna do on
the show I remember Becca Cooper and
entered with a proposal okay so she
could please close your eyes okay bend
your left knee and gently get down Wow
we know how that worked out by II re and
we also had one gal who came in a
wedding dress accelerating accelerating
things I want to give a shout out to
everybody who's ever entered the mansion
in a weird vehicle you know you wouldn't
even know some of these things would
move now Garrett had the minivan hello
okay we get it that's something with an
engine
there was that one girl whose name I
forget an re-season who pulled up in a
race car I love this
we had the guy in the hot tub car I
always wanted they fill that up right
with the hose right away right before I
pulled up probably I used it to wash
down the driveway and somebody showed up
once in a real hearse because love is
dead question mark you guys think love
is dead this took a turn now and now I'm
turning towards a different camera to
try to move forward you know it's gonna
be lets tell me this what will make you
think love is dead what will be the
thing cuz we've had some big breakups in
bachelor world lately that shot what
would mean to you that love is dead for
me the marker is of Tom Hanks and Rita
Wilson breakup Hollywood icons if
they're done I'm done I'm giving up and
I already only really care about hanging
out with myself anyway happiest alone in
my car and with friends but not with
anyway moving forward so we also had
some more unusual vehicles remember one
cupcake came in a cupcake
what is that
and this chick whose name I don't
remember arrived in a piano on wheels
but I want to applaud her for her
coordination because wow she like was
she biking it like was it she had to
pedal like the Flintstones and then she
also had to play I don't remember if
she's saying I want to give a shout out
to people who arrived on animals Blake
Wow didn't work out for anybody seeing a
pattern here arrived normal arrive alive
want to give a shout out to people who
arrived dressed as animals alexis was a
dolphin that David guy was a chicken
[Music]
Jojo were a unicorn mask not a real
animal but is anything real reality TV
oh it's so unicorn soon as this raising
our glasses to people with weird
accessories remember when Carly came
with that karaoke machine I think she's
saying an original song I went out for
Carly song just kidding don't prone out
never pour it out just drink it pour it
out into your mouth and Adam came with
Adam jr. a ventriloquist doll now look
the people on the show the contestants
they can like kind of come up with their
own entrances or if they can't come up
with anything producers will help them
I'm gonna have to ask Adam about this
one I really am like I don't think Adam
is actually a ventriloquist I got to ask
him out the style I'll get back to you
guys okay and now it's not entrances but
I just had to remember and memorialize
this moment do you guys remember Ashley
s the one who was like talking about
onions and I think she thought the onion
or she thought the flowers were onions
every person you meet is like an onion
I just cheers to her because Wow Wow why
why where well she was really getting
out in the mansion you know like not
just on the driveway but like in the in
the shrubbery in the foliage in the
flora and fauna take a freaking look at
the onion and the bush seriously I'm not
eating and those were not hmm
what is your favorite mansion entrance
of all time let me know I want to know
what you think the worst mansion
entrance of all time was and tell me
just your favorite mansion moment cuz
there have been so many like member
there was that Corrine bouncy house
moment I'm not sure that's the greatest
strategy to win the heart of a woman
ryan MacDill jumped in that pool why do
I know Ryan MacDill full name because I
went to college with him very weird
crossovers
I've never revealed this before guys but
Kaitlyn Bristowe season was weird for me
I went to college with Ryan MacDill went
to a couple of fraternity sorority
parties with him I went to high school
with Justin Reich if you remember him we
were like in the exact same friend group
and then Tanner dated one of my best
friends when they were younger
so that season was very meta for me and
a little bit invasive very awkward a
little too real God just like all this
crap over the weekend it's all been too
real everybody luckily I just kept
celebrating my birthday and moving
forward I love California really left
California so much donate if you can't
thank you okay
very quickly rounding out our bachelor
news you can booze only ET exclusively
talk to Amanda Stanton at the revolve
Awards in Las Vegas over the weekend
remember Amanda did have a rough moment
in Vegas mom but we talked to her and
she is just moving forward with her new
man she is so happy and what a sweetie
years our interview with Amanda well I
started here with Bobby which I love and
I love seeing how and
you guys are what is it about him that
makes him so special it's my first
relationship in a long time that I met
somebody in the real world and it's a
lot different he's like such a homebody
he lives close to me and I just feel
like we're kind of like in the same
place in our lives we want all the same
things and I don't know it's just very
easy just nice finishing things off
bachelor news you can booze beard news
you can booze I have nothing to say
other than in Dean Englert seems to have
grown kind of a beard and I applaud him
for it and I gave him an Instagram
comment on it and I liked it please let
me know what you think everybody do we
approve of Dean's beard I'm here for it
he's got an earring I don't love which
I've told him I think the beard is good
it's aging him a little bit in a good
way I like it let me know do we like
Dean's beard okay that's it everyone
let's just rejoice let's soak in the
positivity the bachelor mansion lives to
see another day and another cocktail
partay bum bum every day is a cocktail
party on roses and roses a love you guys
all so much thank you for watching each
week we will be back next week with
another video I wish I could tell you
what it is but honestly so much bachelor
news has happened that I I've stopped
planning ahead you know you never know
what will happen you never know who will
go home but please leave any questions
or comments you have on your favorite
bachelor mansion entrances below and let
me know if you like any fun ideas for
how many they should revamp the mansion
would love to hear all my loves you guys
JC is gonna come out for another one of
our favorite segments on the journey
with JC JC if you were starting your
bachelor journey at the mansion which is
still standing
what would your bachelor mansion
entrance be I'd expect to be the
bachelor
whoa hello
you put on a suit and you're the
bachelor okay babe you deserve to be the
bachelor I agree you do deserve me The
Bachelor hundred percent if you would
vote for JC for Bachelor leave that in
the comments but look the thing is
usually to become the bachelor you have
to start out as a contestant feeder
system so as a contestant what's your
mansion entrance Clydesdales all of them
yep all of them yep like the ones from
that that beer the bunnies are that way
I mean the very back one maybe with soy
maybe with a king's cape i Kitty's very
seriously so Wow full knighthood with JC
okay thank you I love it thinking big
dreaming big as big as the bachelor
mansion is on the journey with JC again
everybody thank you so much please
follow me on Instagram message me
anytime I love you all
[Music]